congressman Devin Nunez represents the
state of California he is of course on
the House Intelligence Committee and he
joins us tonight congressman why
wouldn't do Jay prosecute Jim Comey for
committing a crime that he's admitted to
committing well Tucker I agree with
everything in your opening statement I
think it's every Americans should watch
what you just said I want to actually
make sure though that you understand
what what John Solomon reported on here
because I think it may be getting taken
a little bit out of context the IG
supposedly according to Solomon Solomon
sources made a recommendation okay just
because the DOJ is not going to act
under that recommendation does not mean
he's not going to be further looked at
so remember the US attorney in
Connecticut now is taking all of this
information in so he's taken our
criminal referrals for example so look I
haven't disclosed who we've referred
criminally but I think one could guess
it's highly likely that we would name
people who leaked classified information
so they're not gonna act on any of our
referrals those have all been given to
the US Attorney in Connecticut my guess
is the same holds true for the IG
everything's gonna be given to the
attorney in Connecticut so if I was
James Comey I wouldn't be walking in the
cornfields of Iowa yet running for
president
so if Comey and this sounds like a minor
detail but I don't think it is
if [ __ ] is in fact indicted for the
crime again that he's committed and
admitted committing if that happens will
his house be raided by say 30 armed
federal agents with an officious vehicle
and the collusion of CNN well I would
guess probably not because I believe US
Attorney John Durham is actually a man
who does see the blind lady that doesn't
pull any is not partisan at all and it's
fair and how exactly how justice is
conducted unlike what you saw with the
molar dossier team which now we know
molar wasn't even charged of that
investigation so so I don't believe you
will see that but I do believe that
James Comey will be held accountable and
there's one other point that is
important to make the IG although how
important powers the IG does not have
the power to investigate or compel
people to be interviewed that don't work
at the Department of Justice or or in
the government so I've always been
hesitant to although I appreciate what
the IG is doing they are limited where
John Durham is not limited the US
attorney looking at this so there are a
lot more people that need to be
interviewed even in our investigation
you know we would love to have a law
enforcement arm that we could go out and
and conduct more interviews but but the
the FBI and the US attorney in
Connecticut they have they're building
their team they have a lot of people out
there lot of people that are interviewed
because what we want to make sure is is
that that it's not just James Comey that
gets looked at but this whole fiasco
that's occurred that's it you know you
you just touched on a little bit it in
your opening don't forget the the the
worst it's done them the leaking is
really bad and it was wrong and it was
done to to to incite a special counsel
and poison millions of Americans but the
worst thing I would argue in all of this
is that the spying on the political
campaign began in the first place long
before they told Congress it it began so
this began in early 2016 and it was done
in conjunction with the Hillary Clinton
campaign it doesn't get worse than that
yes by the Obama administration who were
still venerating like gods for some
reason congressman thanks very much
great to see you some reason why Thank
You Tucker